a local business is giving back to
create ukrainians not just through
donations but by helping people escape
and come here to Las Vegas Mary Jane
beliesa shares the story of those
starting a new life here in the United
States it's it's horrible it's you
losing everything in one moment it's
been several months since Julia
palomarchok arrived in the U.S from
Ukraine she operated a beauty salon back
home and was forced to leave after the
Russian invasion thankfully she had the
help of Ohad alamelik her business
partner Ohad is the CEO of jovian's
Eternal a skin care line on the strip
and at the airport with other locations
in Europe and Asia with an already
established Connection in Ukraine he
felt compelled to help even heading to
Poland and the Ukraine border to deliver
essential supplies while picking up
families to bring them to refugee camps
U.S government start with a program
called unite for Ukraine which gave us
the opportunity actually to sponsor
people to come to the US from Ukraine
now we already have over here 15 16
Ukraine paper and we have another a five
that we apply to get approved through
the uniting for Ukraine program he's
able to help other refugees like
Victoria Natalya and Yuri come to Las
Vegas you had friends family and then in
one moment you're losing everything
everything together you come in here and
you're in depression we're trying to do
some gathering for them and like to to
make people feel a little bit better
providing them housing transportation
and proper paperwork to stay and work in
the U.S I hope this story will give
inspiration to other people
to to go and to help to people like our
sponsors help to the people sometimes
it's not enough just to watch the news
and to do some likes or House of the
Facebook or Instagram
sometimes you need to act
essential items baby formula and diapers
are always needed so if you'd like to
help we do have a hot contact
information on our website for you at
8newsnow.com